The Joe Rogan experience.
Hey can I do some but like emotionally activity?
Tell me what it's called.
What is it?
This book is called mentors and I actually I read like I read bits of it again
cause I knew I was coming here.
I think he's actually pretty good.
Like I wrote quite a lot about Brazilian Jujitsu.
You really love it,
Huh?
Yeah I do.
My writing is not from a,
you'll understand not from a technical perspective.
I'm not saying this is why I've got to say on open guard transition.
I'm talking about how the psychological impact that it's had on me and also in
there about like the protocols of going to a group which as a beginner are very
relevant.
Like you touched on how ritualize the eas.
I got a hunch that the more we emulate in connect to original ways of human
behavior,
whether that's diet tree or hierarchies or organization of groups,
I feel that we will spill a sense of greater connection.
Now the,
the thing I got from the guy named Bj Jay classes genesis,
where I'll go in back in England is like that all the white belts get changed.
That one ended a room,
the purple belts and above get changed at the other end of the room,
which coincidentally or not is where the control for the timer is and the
control for the music is and where the kit is that all up.
That room's the end of the room.
So all the control is that end,
but it begins,
we've sort of dancing around in a circle doing all of those various exercises.
Now lift your knees,
now do the shrimp hit and that kind of stuff is that a lower belt shouldn't
invite a higher bell to spa or role,
you know,
it's sat and like the,
as you say,
the amount of respect,
the bowing,
the handshaking at the end of it.
It's so sort of,
it provides such a safe environment in which to deal with the primal.
I can see why it's valuable and it's like,
you know,
I should've been taught that shit when I was 1413 like as Amanda terribly so
that I didn't come across it like,
you know,
not going to be setting fire to feel Jen allotments and put in frogs on
fireworks.
If you've got a way of dealing with that primal energy.
Yeah.
When,
when it's coming so many people that don't understand that think that you should
suppress it somehow you should just ignore it or suppress it.
They don't understand that when men it really ever a biological male,
it really needs to be tackled head on.
I mean you really,
you really need to embrace what it is to be a physical mail and it frees you in
a lot of ways.
Do you think this might be a comparable moment too in the 1960s when there was a
sort of a sense of sexual repression versus sexual free love?
You know,
the images of Woodstock and flowers in their hair and smoking joints and having
sort of sex outdoors in mud or possibly wheat,
that,
that this time of like a kind of an anger about maleness and maleness may not,
as you said,
it may be a biological male bay,
could be the energy of,
I don't know,
assertion or wherever these like,
you know,
as in grammar in male and female,
relate to certain words in French grammar where,
I don't know,
Kat is female and doggies mouth.
I don't know the system.
I don't speak French,
but I'm saying that these,
we have labeled these energies.
Yeah.